[Music]
hold me in place right he's gonna hold
me in place this is the conditioning
right normally time I'd let me push it
right he pushes and then you blend we're
not doing that now we're gonna test our
rotational torque okay so he's not so
that
[Music]
I know robot
it's very tempting to make your Aikido
of all geometry leverage straight so you
want to you're like four kids stop you
see that kid stop get it on my Center
and then I'm gonna well I want to
develop a power that defines geometry
okay because all geometry is about
mechanical advantage and if my engine is
strong enough I could do certain things
with certain geometries that I couldn't
do my engine was not strong enough do
you see that
so he's stabilized and basically I just
found out my power come into my Center
oh you see that
and then we made it a little more
complicated you guys I can't stabilize
like you guys are used to because I have
to move so I'm doing this the movement
right into it so I'm not trying to move
there to get there so I give you a
leverage with that strong engine this is
enough
this is the bottom of the universal I'm
taking this win out there pushing you
see to go to drama okay so we go back to
timing ankle energy you he's feeding me
he's pushing alright and I am going to
do this same movement with my feet side
by side
[Music]
bye-bye find these hip with that's not
what we want not what we want right
underneath my hips mid-foot balance
[Music]
major knees keep your head wide the
Savior once an army or lower okay let's
go drill two three boom
singing Center Park
if we're going to go this is what you
leave out whoa hold elbow
it took my hip discern see then it goes
up look how my hip turns again my hips
don't go in and stay here my hips go
stay still they moved all of the spiral
and it's actually hips that make this
fiber boom here hip hip
like this no hit no hit just arm you see
that and that makes your arms travel out
early to your spine and that's we move
in with my hip back with my tip my arm
is actually going to straight up in my
hips doing it you see whoo hip hip
that's what creates his dollar descent
poppers oh look at the difference you
see that
yes okay let's go you see I bring them
so I'm coming straight up or slow so you
can see what's out I'm shooting it
straight up inside this stripe and I'm
not like this there's no angle to create
the deflection and I'm not going like
this you see that because that angle is
not in incident to his ankle so I have
to make sure I have a sweetie this
timing ever design knitting it
horizontally this other woman is coming
up boom and creates back up let's take
his face
I'm going to come up and use that angle
now often if I do this different you see
this one I can come in and break the
angle right away this stay there goes
here and the rotation is there my hips
are moving you see that my arm does not
go in out that is too weak one
whoa hit boom there's your Kazushi
so you have to stop doing this you come
straight up so hip this is not where you
go straight up in this action but my
hips go back
watch the difference see right
you can't do it on people